Thanks for letting me come over and talk some manuscripts with you.
You
have quite the collection of manuscripts.
Tell me a little bit of the evidence that convinced you as a skeptic to become a
believer. Well, there were actually two things.
One, when I set out to refute Christianity and make a joke of it, I applied
what's called a bibliographical test.
This asks questions of the manuscripts.
manuscripts and the manuscripts are handwritten documents or against printed
documents done on papyrus that's what these are are papyrus and
the papyri after a while will rot away deteriorate the ink will fade and so
they asked two questions one what is the number of manuscripts you have you see the
rule of thumb historically is the more manuscripts you have the easier it is to
reconstruct the original and check out any errors or discrepancies.
Well, when it came to the New Testament with the abundance of new manuscripts
discovered, like right here is one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine manuscripts all discovered in one day.
And six of them are the oldest ever discovered in the New Testament.
And when you take all these manuscripts together, it'll equal right about 2
.6 million pages over 5,800 New Testament manuscripts and
if you took these pages and stacked them one on top another for example the
average classical writer would be about four feet with a New Testament it's one
mile high all of them stacked that's right on top of each other hardly anyone
professor in university anyone knows that and like one of the great Greek scholars
said Josh in these manuscripts we have the original wording of Jesus and now because
of the computers and new
software and everything it'll take him maybe four or five years and will literally
be able to print a New Testament without error without discrepancy of the
exact words of Jesus and the Apostle Paul and everything the closer the copies you
have to the original usually historically the greater the accuracy you have.
Why? Because it usually means it's been copied fewer times and less chance of human
error to leave out a word, leave out a letter, leave out a line as you're copying,
very honestly, to make that mistake.
So intentional or unintentional error can happen in that window.
It's several hundred years, the average age for your great classical
writers, and many of them are 800 to 1,000 year gap between the copies and the
original. With the New Testament, we now go back within 50 years of the original.
I mean, there's nothing else in history compares to it.
And pretty soon with a new manuscript to Mark, which will be released, I believe
it'll take it back, the New Testament, within 30 to 35 years.
So if these are 3rd, 4th century and you said there's 5,800 Greek manuscripts, how
does that compare with the typical work of, say, Plato or Herodotus or Tacitus or
some of the other writers? The New Testament is number one in all history of
manuscript authority. Number two is the Iliad by Homer, with about 1,200 and 1,200,
about 1,800 now, manuscripts. And they're discovering more of the Iliad than any
other classical writer in history.
But when you take the comparison of 5,800 with 1,800 with the New
Testament and number two in history, there's no comparison.
Now I know some critics will push back and say, okay you've got 5,800 Greek
manuscripts. But when you compare the Greek manuscripts there's hundreds or
thousands of differences across these manuscripts.
Yes, but the great number is wonderful!
I thank God for the great number.
You say what?
Yes, because the great number represents the 5,800
manuscripts. You see, if one mistake was made,
for example, they spelled John two different ways or honor the American way, H-O-N-O
-R, the British way, H-O-N-O-U-R, that's a discrepancy.
But say in this manuscript right here, they spelled it H-O-N-O-U-R, mistake.
But in all these other manuscripts, they might've copied 8,000 manuscripts from
there. They just repeated that same misspelling 8,000 times.
But the reason I'm thankful there's more is because if we didn't have more, we
wouldn't have the abundance of manuscripts to understand what Jesus said.
But with all these manuscripts now on the new technology and
software, almost all those are going to be eliminated.
But the majority of them are spelling and grammatical differences.
I've heard Dan Wallace say that probably 75% to 80% of the differences across
the manuscripts are just matters of spelling, the way that you described.
Some are like Mark is a very fast-moving gospel, so the word uses he, but then
they'll insert Jesus for he. So it's a discrepancy, but it brings clarity rather
than confusion. And probably less than 1% has anything to do with meaning,
and none of those have anything to do with a central doctrine.
Is that how you understand it? Why do you love manuscripts so much?
Well, back when I entered the university,
I think I was truly seeking truth.
And I met these Christians and all and professor of the university and their lives
were different. I asked them, why are you so different?
This one young lady looked at me and just said, Jesus Christ.
And I said, oh, for God's sakes, don't give me that garbage.
I thought it was a joke. Well, they made me so mad because every day they challenged
me to intellectually examine it so I said okay I will well one thing I did I went to
Israel I'd made a lot of money as a student with a painting company and I went to
all throughout the United States England Germany France Switzerland in the Middle
East gathering evidence studying the manuscripts and the scrolls to show they were
unreliable not
trustworthy so to disprove it right against it that's right here and I had
returned to London overnight before flying back to the United States, and I went
to the small museum library looking at some of the manuscripts.
Finally, I leaned back in my chair, and just right out loud I said, it's true, it's
true, it's true. I came back to university.
Finally, I couldn't sleep. I trusted Christ as Savior and Lord.
Then I prayed, God, someday can I own some of these artifacts, manuscripts
scrolls and others that you use to convince me of its truth that I can use
to share it with others so that's why I love the manuscripts plus it's the
manuscripts they give you the access to what Jesus said taught and did now I know
some critics will push back and go okay wait a minute all right maybe the text has
been reconstructed accurately to a degree but when you look across say the gospels
there's contradictions one says there's one angel at the tomb one says there's
a young man, one says there's two angels.
They describe the time that Jesus comes to the tomb differently.
Well, you have to remember we're 2,000 years removed.
It's a different language, everything.
So you're going to have alleged, I always put alleged discrepancies.
I think you can intellectually defend alleged discrepancies.
I don't think you can intellectually defend discrepancies because over the years,
one after another are being explained.
For example, one place it says that Jesus did the miracle going into Jericho and the
other says he did it coming out of Jericho.
And they said, see, they're an absolute thing.
But what they later found out, there were two Jerichos, an old and new, one inside
the other. And so yes, he was going into Jericho and going out of Jericho at the
same time doing it.
And so a lot of it is a misunderstanding of the grammar, of the meaning of the word.
But this is why manuscripts and archaeological discoveries are so incredible.
So I put it this way, you can intellectually defend alleged discrepancy.
And there are some, I can't explain them away, but I have confidence in this, they
will be explained because I can look back over hundreds that have been explained
away. So when you first became a Christian, 50 plus years ago, partly by examining
the scriptures, now you've been reading books, studying this firsthand yourself for
over five decades. How do you look at the confidence and reliability of the
scriptures given the time that you've had to study this?
Oh, my confidence in the scriptures has skyrocketed.
I really believe the greater the knowledge, the greater the confidence when it comes
to the scriptures. And with this tsunami of New Testament and Old Testament, with
the scrolls and all discoveries, it's just
built upon my confidence, but ultimately my confidence is in the person
of Jesus Christ. Was he who he claimed to be?
And did he do what he claimed he was going to do on the cross for our sins and what
others said? That is the basis of my faith in the person of Jesus Christ
and the scriptures.
Amen. Thanks, Dad. It's been fantastic.
Sure appreciate it.